[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es ein leckeres Grillrezept.
Ich habe mir gedacht, das Wetter ist schön,
wir schmeißen den Grill an
und machen heute Putenspieße mit Gemüse.
Ja.
Zuerst werde ich jetzt mal das Fleisch marinieren.
Das könnt ihr wunderbar vorbereiten,
gerne auch am Abend vorher
oder einfach eine Stunde vorher.
Das reicht vollkommen aus.
Ich mache so eine,
ja, ich würde schon sagen, eine asiatische Marinade.
Ich glaube, das wird ziemlich lecker.
Dafür nehme ich
70 Gramm Sojasauce,
70 Gramm Sonnenblumenöl,
drei Teelöffel Sesamöl,
drei Knoblauchzehen,
– okay, das ist ein bisschen türkisch –
etwas Pfeffer und Salz
und 1,3 Kilo Putenfleisch.
Okay, asiatisch-türkisch.
Nein, türkisch wären 15 Knoblauch.
Das ist Fakt!
Weißt du, was ich vergessen habe tatsächlich?
Ich wollte noch eine leichte Süße reinbringen.
Wir nehmen noch
das, was ich dahabe,
[Musik]
Ahornsirup.
Wir nehmen noch zwei Esslöffel Ahornsirup oder Honig
oder was ihr so dahabt.
Ich nehme noch ein bisschen Honig.
So.
Jetzt ist es asiatisch.
So ein bisschen süß muss schon sein.
Das Fleisch habe ich übrigens schon in Würfel geschnitten,
in so etwa drei bis vier Zentimeter große.
Einfach nur darauf achten,
dass sie ungefähr gleichmäßig sind.
Okay.
Jetzt gebt ihr alle Zutaten im Prinzip
nur noch in eine Schüssel.
Die Sojasauce, die sorgt halt wirklich für die Würze.
Also
wird das schon lecker würzig gleich.
Ich habe so eine Auskratzkrankheit.
Ich muss alles auskratzen, jedes Glas.
Sesamöl mit rein.
Die Knoblauchzehen, die braucht ihr nicht schälen,
wenn ihr eine Knoblauchpresse habt.
Aber, wenn ihr sie fein reibt oder hakt,
müsst ihr sie natürlich schälen.
Ich habe gestern allein drei Knoblauchzehen gegessen,
so ganz allein.
Ja, ist so.
Warte, jetzt machen wir erst mal den leer.
Und so ungefähr zwei Esslöffel Süße, okay?
So.
Warte, das dauert zu lang.
Das stellen wir auf den Kopf.
So.
Noch Honig rein.
Ui! Der ist ein bisschen
– uh! –
fest geworden.
Uh!
Okay, das reicht.
Wow!
Da gibt es übrigens den Tipp,
das in warmes Wasser zu stellen.
Und dann
geht es wieder einfacher.
Jetzt noch Salz und Pfeffer
und dann war es das auch schon.
[Musik]
Hier noch den Rest.
So.
Sehr schwäbisch.
Und jetzt gebt ihr hier einfach das Fleisch rein.
Jetzt könnt ihr es entweder verkneten oder verrühren.
[Musik]
Und jetzt deckt ihr das Fleisch entweder ab
und es kommt in den Kühlschrank
und darf für etwa
mindestens eine Stunde bis einen Tag marinieren.
Ich mache es jetzt aber so,
weil wir nämlich gleich essen wollen,
werde ich es vakuumieren.
So kommen nämlich die Aromen
wirklich direkt ins Fleisch rein
und ich muss gar nicht so lange warten.
Und außerdem habe ich dann
das Fleisch in einem Beutel drin,
habe es schön luftdicht verpackt,
kann es im Kühlschrank lagern
oder auch zu meinen Freunden zum Beispiel mitnehmen
und habe es einfach schön sicher darin.
Das sieht wunderbar aus!
Ihr könnt übrigens, wenn ihr so eine große Schüssel habt,
– guckt mal –
den großen Emailleteller nehmen,
drauf legen
und dann ist es auch wunderbar abgedeckt
und ihr könnt sogar die Schüsseln stapeln.
Also nur mal so als
Lifehack.
Jetzt gebe ich hier das Fleisch aber,
weil ich es ja vakuumieren möchte,
in meinen Vakuumbeutel.
Und dann habt ihr wirklich innerhalb von Sekunden
das komplette Aroma im Fleisch drinnen
und müsst nicht ewig warten.
Man kann auch einen großen Löffel nehmen,
aber man muss nicht.
Und schön auskratzen!
Oder, ob du meine blöden Witze wirklich witzig findest.
"Ha, ich lache mal mit."
>> JOSH: Ja.
Ich äußere mich dazu nicht.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Was meint ihr? Lacht Josh nur aus Anstand mit?
Oder weil er mich lustig findet?
So.
Und ganz wichtig,
jetzt mal, um wieder zum Ernst zurückzukommen:
Wenn ihr Geflügel schneidet, ist wirklich superwichtig,
dass ihr eure Werkzeuge danach gründlich reinigt.
Ja.
Also jetzt nicht auf dem gleichen Schneidebrett
Gemüse und Salat schneiden,
sondern wirklich gründlich reinigen.
Und ja, wollte ich nur sagen.
Okay.
[Musik]
Was ihr hier gerade blubbern seht,
das ist der Unterdruck, der entsteht.
Und so zieht wirklich die Marinade sofort ins Fleisch ein.
[Musik]
So.
Guckt mal.
Perfekt einvakuumiert.
Jetzt kann ich das Fleisch kurz in den Kühlschrank stellen
und mich um das Gemüse kümmern.
Denn das werden nicht nur Putenspieße,
sondern Puten-Gemüse-Spieße.
Das Fleisch ist mariniert.
Jetzt kommt hier noch das Gemüse ins Spiel.
Ich nehme jetzt hier einfach noch Champignons dazu,
Zucchini, Cocktailtomaten,
rote Zwiebeln und weiße Zwiebeln.
Und hier habe ich einfach noch mal die Marinade gemacht,
die ich eben auch für das Fleisch gemacht habe.
Die Zwiebeln, die werde ich jetzt einfach nur vierteln.
Die dürfen gerne so groß bleiben.
Da könnt ihr im Prinzip nehmen, was euch schmeckt.
Also ich habe jetzt einfach mal
so eine schöne bunte Mischung gemacht.
Ich finde auch so kleine Zwiebeln süß,
weil dann könnt ihr die im Ganzen drauf stecken.
Bei der Zucchini einfach
das Anfangsstück und das Endstück weg.
Und je nach Durchmesser reicht es,
wenn ihr sie einfach in große Stücke schneidet,
oder ihr müsst sie eben doch noch halbieren.
Ich glaube, ich werde sie schon noch halbieren,
weil die doch recht dick sind,
und dann aber in breite Stücke schneiden.
Im Prinzip einfach jetzt alles ungefähr gleich groß schneiden.
[Musik]
Die Champignons sind auch ziemlich ungleich.
Also die kleinen hier, die lasse ich jetzt im Ganzen.
Und die großen, die halbiere ich jetzt einfach nur.
Da muss ich schon sagen,
dass ich jetzt nicht so der große Fleischesser bin.
Deswegen gibt es bei mir beim Grillen
immer ganz viel Gemüse entweder in Form von Salaten
oder in Form von einer Gemüsepfanne
oder eben Gemüsespieße.
So.
Was haben wir noch?
Die Paprika.
Und da schneide ich den Boden weg
und die vier Seiten.
Und dann habt ihr da auch schon so eine schöne Fläche.
[Musik]
Ich will nur kurz betonen, dass Frau Ich-verschwende-nichts
wirklich nichts verschwendet.
Ja.
Denn das könnt ihr noch essen, okay?
Ich habe es zwar vorhin so schön quadratisch abgeschnitten
an der nichtquadratischen Paprika,
aber die Dinger hier, die müsst ihr noch wegessen,
müsst ihr mir versprechen.
So.
Jetzt braucht ihr Spieße.
Ich probiere jetzt mal die hier aus.
Denn die haben so einen Schieber.
Vielleicht klappt es ja ganz gut.
Okay.
Und jetzt im Prinzip einfach nur aufspießen.
Ich habe es ganz gerne,
wenn sie gleichmäßig aufgespießt sind alle,
das heißt überall so das Gleiche drauf.
Abwechselnd mal Fleisch, mal Gemüse.
Ja.
Das sieht doch gut aus.
Die Tomate spare ich mir, glaube ich, bis zum Schluss auf.
Eine Zwiebel muss unbedingt mit auf so einen Spieß!
Und ich mache es jetzt einfach so,
immer ein Stück Fleisch, ein Stück Gemüse.
Und dann, finde ich, reicht auch so ein Spieß
für eine Frau wie mich
und drei für Josh.
Oder, Josh? Passt das dann für dich?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> JOSH: Mit Beilage oder ohne Beilage?
>> SALLY: Mit Beilage natürlich.
>> SALLY: Also das...
>> JOSH: Dann sind auch zwei okay.
>> SALLY: Dann sind zwei auch okay, nicht?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Weil ich finde, es muss nicht immer
so viel Fleisch sein beim Grillen
>> JOSH: Nee.
>> SALLY: oder auch mal gar keines.
Also ihr könnt auch mal nur die
Gemüsespieße machen mit der Marinade.
Das ist auch okay.
Oh, ich liebe Zucchini!
Zucchini müssen zwei.
Ja, das sieht doch...
Ich glaube, ein bisschen mehr Rot wäre schön gewesen.
Aber da kommt ja jetzt gleich die Tomate noch.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier.
So legen wir das jetzt hier ab.
Und jetzt versuche ich, alle anderen Spieße
exakt so zu machen.
Ich glaube, ich schmiere das so ein bisschen vorher.
Ja.
[Musik]
So sehen die Spieße jetzt aus.
Und ich gebe jetzt hier einfach noch über das Gemüse
so ein bisschen die Marinade drüber.
Und die können dann im Prinzip schon direkt auf den Grill.
Ich werde jetzt noch ein paar vegane Spieße machen
für unsere Veganer hier im Haus.
Das heißt, ich hebe ein bisschen Marinade auf
und spieße einfach nur Gemüse auf
ohne Fleisch.
Und dann sehen wir uns gleich draußen am Grill.
Ich muss echt sagen, ich bin so schlecht im Grillfeuermachen.
Also ich glaube, da muss ich mir selber mal
so YouTube-Tutorials angucken.
Gut, der Grill ist jetzt auch nicht der beste.
Aber ich meine, Grillen, ganz ehrlich,
ein bisschen Feuer, ein bisschen Kohle.
Ja.
Und Feuer,
ich finde, Feuer machen, das müssen die Männer.
So.
Wir Frauen bereiten schon das Essen zu
und die Männer, die machen das Feuer.
Und, da heute der Murat nicht da ist,
weiß ich, wer das Feuer heute macht.
Josh, du bist der Auserwählte!
Ach, schön!
Und guck mal, ich habe ganz wenig Gemüse nur übrig.
Also es ging echt fast komplett auf.
Und, wenn ich jetzt nicht noch an die Veganer denken würde,
würde ich einfach so einen Gemüsespieß,
so einen Restespieß machen.
Hat man ja immer, das was nicht aufgeht.
Und ja, ich mache noch kurz Gemüsespieße
und dann sind wir am Grill,
an dem wunderbaren Feuer von Josh.
[Musik]
Jetzt kann ich die Spieße grillen.
Und da einfach aufpassen,
dass wirklich Geflügel gut durchgegart verzehrt wird.
Unter mehrmaligem Wenden jetzt einfach schön durchgaren.
Ich mache es dann oft so, dass ich einfach
beim ersten Spieß mal kurz durchprobiere und schaue.
Und dann könnt ihr da auch Gewissheit haben,
dass sie wirklich schön durch sind.
[Musik]
So. Eine Botschaft an meine Zuschauer
und die ist wirklich ernst zu nehmen:
Könnt ihr bitte in die Kommentare schreiben,
dass mein Mann mir mal einen gescheiten Grill holt?
Ich mache so leckeres Essen,
ich bereite alles so toll vor
und dann habe ich einfach so einen Grill,
auf dem ich nicht wirklich grillen kann.
Ich hätte gern, glaube ich, einen eckigen Grill
und dann einfach einen, wo ich Spieße und alles Mögliche
alleine schön grillen kann,
wo das Feuermachen nicht so schwer ist
und einfach
der meinem Essen würdig ist.
Bitte schreibt es rein. Okay?
Danke!
Dann mache ich noch mehr leckere Grillrezepte.
Also hier seht ihr diese Öffnung.
Ja, die war bis vor Kurzem nicht da.
Da kam mein Papa und wir haben Köfte gegrillt.
Und Köfte, ich habe da so...
Ihr kennt doch diesen Grillaufsatz da für
Fisch zum Beispiel oder Gemü-
– oder für Spieße!
Na ja, egal.
Jedenfalls hat der Grillaufsatz da nicht so drauf gepasst
und dann hat mein Papa sich gedacht,
"Du, dann flexe ich das hier einfach weg",
und hat mir ein Loch in meinen Kugelgrill reingeflext,
der zum Glück schon uralt ist.
Aber ich habe nichts gesagt,
weil ich wollte der Papa einfach...
Der hat es ja gut gemeint.
Und dann habe ich gesagt:
"Super, Papa, hast du das gemacht! Echt!
Iyi fikir!
Super Einfall!"
Und der hat sich gefreut.
Nur, wenn wir jetzt einen neuen Grill holen,
dann sollte er das vielleicht nicht machen,
weil dann wäre es vielleicht
ein bisschen schade.
[Musik]
Guckt mal.
Die Spieße sehen nach dem Grillen wunderbar aus!
Und ich probiere das jetzt mal aus an einem.
Ich habe es jetzt ein bisschen abkühlen lassen.
Normalerweise muss man halt grillen,
einfach grillen und dann direkt auf den Tisch und sofort essen.
Aber ihr wisst, wir fotografieren dann immer noch alles.
Ich probiere das jetzt mal.
Oh ja!
Ich bin begeistert!
Es klappt.
Und dann kann man das schön essen.
Am besten noch ein paar Grillbeilagen dazu machen.
Dazu habe ich auch schon ein Video gemacht.
Ich habe sowieso allgemein schon einige Grillvideos gemacht.
Schaut euch gerne die Videos dazu an!
Und dann wünsche ich euch einen guten Appetit!
Ich hoffe und bete,
dass ich bald einen schöneren Grill bekomme, auf dem ich
wirklich gut grillen kann.
Bitte schreibt es einfach in die Kommentare. Okay?
Das ist so unsere interne Abmachung.
Also bis zum nächsten Mal!
Und Tschüss!
[Musik]